[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté qu'est ce que vous nous faites
aujourd'hui eh bien on va faire une
gigue de chevreuil sauce grand veneur ça
c'est un pas de fait mais nous il faut
beaucoup de choses pour faire cette
recette
oui oui mais à la portée de tout le
monde des carnets mais bon il faut
d'abord un bond vers saint louis 1 à 2
un bon bordeaux bien corsé oui parce que
vous m'avez expliqué que le vin c'est
pour la marine avec les vins légers pour
la marinade ce n'est pas sexy c'est pas
suffisant
ensuite il faut quoi d'autre après il
nous faut de la rentrée il faut des 40
et nous faut un peu de céleri
il faut du persil il nous faut des noix
de muscade
il nous faut du thym du laurier de
l'oignon du terme voilà delahaye de
l'échalote de la gelée de groseille de
la crème fraîche des baies de genièvre
des clous de girofle un foie gras et
notre ligue fort logique elle est
superbe mais vous m'étonnez parce que je
ne savais pas que dans la gigue de
chevreuil sauce grand veneur il fallait
mettre du foie gras ah non non non non
non et non
le foie gras les magnifiques j'en ai
profité pour vous le présenter
mais ça se voir à eelv après il va
servir pour faire notre terrine de
cheveux qu'on fera on suit voilà après
très bien alors la première des choses
c'est de faire la marine intérêts
évidemment
voilà nous avons montré déjà souvent
comment on fait une marinade dans
d'autres émissions
alors on ne va pas recommencer là nous
avions préparé déjà une gigue de
chevreuil qui a mariné pendant 24 heures
alors maïté il faut bien montrer elle a
requis une chaire couleur que la wii qui
a complètement changé de couleur devant
changer
et qu'est ce que vous avez lu faire mais
bon alors je vais d'allah des
c'est-à-dire avec ma petite ventrèche je
vais enfoncé la voilà là dedans ça va le
dans la chine oui ça va donner une
panoplie de saveur voilà vous donner un
goût plus qu'amer la marinade où il y
avait des carottes de l'union du vin
comme on a dit et plein de bonnes choses
elle a déjà beaucoup de goût cette digue
mais il faut rajouter quand même un
petit peu mais suit ensuite je l'avais
dans un plat bon bien à plat que sanofi
avait la même parce que
là on l'est tous les légumes la casse
qui développe un bris et en voilà et
ensuite elle va aller directement au
four non non je vais même la grèce de la
graisse de canard ou parce que dans
certaines recettes on parle de barde
mais au fond quand on a la chance
d'avoir de la graisse de canard c'est
encore meilleur mais bien sûr non ici on
a connu bonne chose car pendant soit
vous avez mis le four à chaux fait très
fort et voyant notre fort très fort et
fort parce qu'il faut qu'ils soient
enseignants et enseignantes et revoilà
eh bien je vais la faire et on fout et
ça va être à peu près de combien de
temps fou au vert minutes au plus soit
pas plus c'est pas énorme ça nous laisse
le temps évidemment j'imagine que vous
allez faire quelque chose avec la marine
oui alors je vais mettre ma casserole
sur le feu
oui et je vais mettre toute cette
marinade dans la casserole y compris les
légumes
exactement oui et je vais te laisser
réduire de moitié au moins avec tous les
légumes et avait une petite fille oui
voilà
et je vais laisser bouillir le tout
voilà rien ne se gaspille là et ça va
cuire et pendant que ça réduit on
pourrait peut-être faire la terrible
mais bien sûr alors comment fait-on
alors voilà on va escaloper un peu il
faut prendre de jolies tranches de
chevreuils sur des passes de l'intérêt
de kokomian les grandes et oui pour nous
en la petite
oui nous on a fait passer juste pour
vendre très dur voilà deux jours les
escalopes de cheveux oui de gigot que je
vais passer juste aller retour à la
poêle dans la poêle bien chaude
saler poivrer
seul a retourné pas longtemps parce que
c'est ça mon chrono de rose sont c'est à
peine après du doré à faire dorer voilà
et ça suffit on ne sait presque rien il
n'a pas beaucoup on a le seul à pendant
ce temps je vais finir marashi alors le
hachis vous aurez mis quoi dedans
le hachis à la ventrèche oui il ya de
l'échalote
oui il ya un petit peu de livres métro
je vais rajouter maintenant l'euro oui
un petit morceau de la wii on sait pas
faire le pas du premier choix non vous
prenez le casino de la rue ou
éventuellement quelque chose que vous
avez à dire allant de l'art de tom petit
bout de jardin oui c'est une seule il
faut pas mettre tout parce que c'est le
sèche
oui c'est bon mais il faut mais est ce
que ça donne à notre niveau il suffit ça
suffit et voudra j'ai dit à ma démarche
oui on va le 112 est obligé de sel et
poivre et la farce où je parle à peine
petit clip qu'on aide un peu voilà si
antoine et s'ils ont connu notre
ventrèche si on connaît notre voilà ça y
est ça va je vois là la salle et la
pauvre est un tout petit peu je vais
pousser je vais y mettre un petit peu de
savoir s'il faut le relever que dans les
mains oui et puis je vais y mettre de
l'armagnac du preneur mayotte ce combat
là où l'autre ce qu'on a souvent un
alcool en alcool qui donne donc là ici
tout je mélange de tous oui voilà avec
les maires et bien sûr oui comme les
romains tout et ça y est et avec ça on
voit monter la terrine aux rencontres la
terrine et c'est maintenant que le foie
gras va nous servir oui alors comment
va-t-on faire
eh bien on va monter d'un terrible c'est
à dire c'est pas difficile on va
commencer par mettre quelque part parce
c'est des petites lanières découpée dans
une barde de lard de porc il veut regret
c'est un petit peu le fort ensuite après
on va mettre une couché de notre phare
c'est notre force vient aromatisée avec
le cognac où l'armagnac sommes encore on
veut paraître
ensuite on va mettre la viande que j'ai
fait revenir le droit jusqu'à lob de
chevreuil légèrement revenu dans de la
graisse de canard au chaud à peine
revenu vous a fait quoi et on voit très
bien ils sont encore rose et à oui mais
a peiné parce que ce serait comme dire à
coeur fait bien sûr lensois grand a
le programme alors je prends là il faut
pas tarder
c'est une jolie oula ça c'est une belle
escalope de foie gras
vous savez on a mangé
ouais voilà foie gras de canard venant
du cru oui frais l'oréal cède habitait
la région
à ce moment là où on tue le canard le
matin si on peut dire et puis on a le
droit
on a vraiment frais et là on arrange
bien d'autres terrines et on remet de
labarde pour faire joli juste pour
décorer parce que les grandes villes
we wanna c'est pour rendre plus
appétissant oui ça y est alors comment
la mettez vous là dessus mais pareil
sort il ya autre chose que je me demande
c'est pourquoi est-ce que vous avez mis
cette terrine dans un autre plat il ya
une raison sur robert mari ou d'un mari
elle va cuire au bain-marie
comme tout le monde sait ce que c'est
qu'un mari c'est à dire vous amener de
l'eau voilà on met de l'eau comme ceux
ci l'a naturellement on allie le four à
sofia va chauffer très chaud bien
entendu il est très chaud très chaud
alors il fait chaud et lada dans notre
bon four et il faut compter à peu près
combien de temps maintenant
1h20 s'agissant des épaisseurs boncelles
la palmeraie mais si on a fait pour la
maison on va faire une plus grande
oui bon alors il faut compter une seule
avait 25 35 minutes ça suffit ça suffit
et si on en fait tout petit pour deux
minutes très vite et d'apprendre que sa
cuisine autre chose continue notre sauce
grand veneur à réduire elle va bientôt
être à point et on va pouvoir infini
bien sûr on la passe on respire est
posté avec les petits légumes qui était
double offrir une chance oui voilà
savard et ensuite tous oui c'est ça qui
donne un peu de corps illégalement génie
sont fait plaisir
voilà je vais maintenant je veux mais le
tout dans la casserole
ces mêmes pavés voilà je remets sur le
feu et c'est là que je rajoute un peu du
bon bouillon que vous aviez préparé à la
voile parce qu'une bonne cuisinière a
toujours un bouillon sur le coin du feu
et la boue dont vous aviez mis comme
vous nous direz vous les trois là
c'était de la poule d arêtes goût du
neuf les légumes et tout ça et ensuite
ça va encore ribis enfin j'en rêve une
fois même plus et puis la recette sera
terminé quand ça sera réduit comme nous
allons voir oui on a sorti du four maïté
et la gigue de chevreuil et la terrine
qui sont cuites
alors la terrine il va falloir attendre
qu elle refroidit que je vais voir des
cahiers bien que woody et surtout pas la
couper avant quasiment complètement
cahier quant à la gigue nous couper une
petite tranche vous finissez la sauce je
vais finir la sauce avant alors qu'est
ce qu'il lui faut encore à cette sauce
folk a réduit est devenu tout à fait et
pas voulu la révéler alors je vais
mettre un petit peu de gelée de
groseille zad aussi beaucoup la voilà
nice est tous un peu de crème fraîche
oui là je vais remuer la com ça vous
faire fondre dans la jourée fasse rire
la crème de sa famille et là quelques
risques en fait bien pleine et si tu as
fait pour ce fou de soul et je la sors
et maintenant qu'elle va bien se vendre
je vais couper de tranchées de magic a
fait la surprise
il faut pas se rendre et quid
on va voir là il est à
c'est beaucoup plus joli un peu rose et
c'est ce qu'il faut bien tout ce qu'ils
ont envie d'en manger
voilà la superbe magnifique et je vais
nappé de ma belle sauce voilà ça c'est
d'amener de roi tout est fondu et bien
lié la consistance qu'il nous faut et
bon appétit
voilà je crois que maïté vous a fait un
joli cadeau vous montrons cette jolie
sauce il faut bien entendu avoir un beau
cuissot de chevreuil retrouve pas
partout dans sa région il y en a
beaucoup trop même alors on en fait
souvent alors à vous d'essayer d'en
trouver
à vous d'essayer de faire ses recettes
et vous ne regretterez pas alors au
revoir et à bientôt
merci et bon appétit
[Musique]